[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en directo américa de france 24 en esta
oportunidad me acompaña a cristina
aparte ya es la presidenta de la corte
constitucional de colombia cristina
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francioni 4 para
nosotros es un honor que esté con
nosotros el honor es mío muchas gracias
por la invitación mucho saludo para
todos los televidentes christina estamos
aquí también como en el marco de lo que
hicimos en las entrevistas de la feria
del libro porque precisamente la corte
constitucional publicó este libro que se
llama los guardianes de la constitución
a rescate del artículo 44 un proyecto
que tuvo muchísimo trabajo más de 17
meses
trabajando sobre todo por los niños para
que los niños conozcan una constitución
que es un libro tan complejo no como
cómo hacer todo este proceso de creación
para la comprensión de un niño que
conozca una constitución de un país en
este caso la de colombia bueno este es
un trabajo que duró mucho tiempo en
llevar a cabo se hicieron se trabajó con
200 niños en 17 meses de trabajo se
escogieron digamos 12 relatos sacados de
sentencias de la corte constitucional
con la intención de hacer pedagogía o de
dar herramientas pedagógicas también a
los profesores para para que los niños
entiendan que es la constitución cuáles
son sus derechos se empoderen de la
defensa de los mismos el proyecto además
se orientó a distintas poblaciones a
poblaciones de niños de escuelas
públicas de escuelas privadas del campo
de la ciudad niños
digamos de alguna
con alguna
sociedad étnica o de algún grupo étnico
en niños en condiciones de discapacidad
tratando de acercar a su lenguaje ya su
idiosincrasia
la labor de la corte constitucional fue
el fixing unir este proceso jurídico y
pedagógico o fue de manera como muy
orgánico o sea no fue tan difícil desde
poder crearlo no para plasmarlo pues
pues necesitamos ayuda después de
docentes porque por supuesto el lenguaje
que maneja un tribunal constitucional no
es el lenguaje que los niños están
acostumbrados a oír entonces hay que
acudir a recursos didácticos como
imágenes como a un formato como de si de
narración con dibujos para hacerlo más
accesible este libro también se basa en
el artículo 44 de la constitución de
colombianos para explicar un poco de qué
se trata este artículo 44 por favor es
el que se refiere a los derechos de los
niños las niñas y los adolescentes y les
da prioridad sobre los demás se refiere
al interés al interés superior del menor
en nuestra constitución
este este libro también tiene una
finalidad de enfocarlo a los niños pero
uno también como adulto un libro tan
robusto como una constitución sobre todo
la constitución como como la de colombia
cómo hacer uno como adulto para
acercarse más para para conocer más los
derechos de uno como ciudadano qué
recomendación le puede dar no ser una
persona que nos está viendo ahora bueno
pues el lenguaje de la corte a veces es
un lenguaje técnico aunque pues la corte
misma hace esfuerzos por difundir la
constitución entre todas las poblaciones
ha traducido la constitución incluso a
distintas lenguas ha traducido
sentencias a lenguajes indígenas tiene
una página pues una relatoría a la corte
constitucional y tiene una página de la
relatoría de la corte constitucional que
es de muy fácil acceso para la población
de muy fácil búsqueda pero por supuesto
estos esfuerzos son tiene que ser
continuados tienen que ser permanentes
tienen que ser acompañados de expertos
en comunicación para poder hacerle
entender a toda la ciudadanía cuál es la
mejor manera de defender sus derechos
las sentencias de la corte pues lo que
buscan es hacer realidad sobre todo las
sentencias de tutela a ser efectivos en
la vida real los derechos de las
personas que no se queden escritos en la
constitución sino que no sean
programático sino que que realmente se
puedan ejercer esos derechos
fundamentales entonces si se difunden
las sentencias de la corte la gente
entiende que si está en una situación
parecida tiene una herramienta que en
colombia es la acción de tutela y que
puede acudir ante los jueces
constitucionales para para lograr la
protección de los derechos entonces es
una herramienta poderosa de saneamiento
de afianzamiento de la democracia en la
que precisamente cómo hacer eso cómo
hacer para que se respete más esa
constitución que muchas veces es difícil
obviamente hacerla respetar o que se
cumpla todo todo lo que dice la
constitución porque también hay muchas
interpretaciones cómo hacer
pues la la justicia constitucional es
una herramienta poderosa pero para que
la justicia constitucional sea
verdaderamente transformadora pues tiene
que el primero hace mucha pedagogía para
que la ciudadanía sea se empodere de la
acción de tutela y pueda acudir con ella
ante la jurisdicción constitucional en
la deferencia de sus derechos ese es el
primer paso
también es muy importante lograr el
cumplimiento de las sentencias para
hacer que nuestra constitución deje de
ser como un ideal como un proyecto de
sociedad como un programa de trabajo y
llegue a ser pues una constitución
vigente viva actual y que regule es
decir que transforme realmente la
realidad christina y como es ser la
presidenta de la corte constitucional de
un país tan complejo como colombia
además bueno
es un poco de trabajo adicional es como
poner la cara ponerle cara a la corte
constitucional lo cual exige pues
dedicarle tiempo dar entrevistas como
éstas contar que hace la corte
comunicar las sentencias que prefiere
etcétera en eso consiste ese presidente
fue difícil llegar al puesto que tiene
usted ahora bueno pues yo no soy
propiamente jovencita
tengo una trayectoria larga en pues en
el ejercicio mi profesión inicialmente
pues trabajé en otras áreas del derecho
luego me oriente por el derecho
constitucional fui profesora
pues estuve vinculada a la academia en
la universidad de la qualy grecia en la
universidad del rosario y después empecé
a trabajar en la corte constitucional
donde trabajé 14 años y medio como
magistrado auxiliar es decir redactando
trabajando en la escritura de las
sentencias después de eso tuve una
experiencia muy enriquecedora que fue
trabajar para la rama ejecutiva fui la
secretaría jurídica de la presidencia de
la república de colombia durante seis
años y medio lo que me permitió ver las
cosas como desde desde el ángulo del
gobierno y después de eso pues vine a la
corte a partir de 2017 soy magistrado de
la corte constitucional christina cuando
usted es el cargo que quiere dejar cómo
quiere ser recordado
pues como defensora de la democracia y
de los derechos de las personas creo que
ese es el objetivo de la corte es ese
defender los derechos fundamentales de
los colombianos y los principios básicos
los ejes axiales de nuestra democracia
que pues son una riqueza inmensa entre
una sociedad una sociedad
democrática es una sociedad mucho más
pues satisfactoria me parecía que
cualquier otro modelo de gobierno
también aquí hay algo histórico porque
usted es la presidente también la
vicepresidenta es una es una mujer que
le diría a las personas que están viendo
sobre todo a una niña que no fue
sabiendo con su mamá en nuestro programa
en este espacio en ese espacio de
directo américa de france24 y decir yo
quiero llegar a ser a lo mejor una
magistral yo quiero ser la presidenta de
la cuarta confesional o una presidenta
como como alentar a esas niñas que pues
a lo mejor no la tienen tan fácil a
mentalmente por pues también por ser
niña en esta sociedad que estamos viendo
para decirles sigue adelante continúa
que si se puede si se puede cumplir todo
lo que usted quiera bueno pues no
solamente la vicepresidenta y la
presidenta somos mujeres sino que la
corte constitucional está compuesta por
nueve magistrados de los cuales cinco
son mujeres y cuatro hombres entonces es
una corte mayoritariamente femenina en
este momento creo que eso es un hito
histórico no sólo en colombia en américa
latinael sino a nivel global es una
corte constitucional mayoritariamente
femenina lo cual pues da una
una perspectiva de interpretación
jurídica importante porque porque la
visión femenina
de los problemas pues contribuye de
mejor manera a su solución
[Música]
y vamos a tener ese enfoque de género
necesario para lograr equidad en la
sociedad yo que les diría a las niñas ya
los estudiantes de derecho no no es tan
difícil finalmente se vienen rompiendo
lo que se llaman los techos de cristal
es decir finalmente se está eligiendo a
las personas no por si son hombres o si
son mujeres sino por su trayectoria
académica ese es eso no sucedía hace
unos 20 años cuando o 30 cuando se fundó
la corte constitucional ahora la gente
no mira así si el candidato es mujer o
es hombre sino mira su trayectoria mira
a su récord mira tal vez su orientación
ideológica y pues así el senado de la
república ha procedido y ha procedido a
elegir mujeres hasta llegar a tener una
corte constitucional mayoritaria
anímense todas las niñas que quieran ser
abogadas y todas las estudiantes de
derecho es es una vocación
muy satisfactoria administrar justicia
constitucional es el mejor escenario
para ejercer la carrera de derecho sino
que también lo dijo hace 20 años no a lo
mejor no ha sido tan fácil no fácil pues
te votan tan naturales como lo puedo
hacer ahora tuvo que tener mucho
carácter para llegar a donde está ahora
tuve que trabajar mucho y lo intenté
tres veces antes de antes de llegar a
ser elegida trabajé también muy duro en
el área específica derecho
constitucional pues siempre he sido
servidora pública pues desde que dejé la
cadencia servidora pública y pues es el
uno servidor público
también es una vocación muy especial se
trabaja duro se trabaja largas jornadas
es una experiencia ardua pero muy
gratificante también para la tercera la
vencida no a christina ante de la
ventilla quisiera muchísimas gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en este espacio
de france 24 directo américa la verdad
ha sido un gusto poder conversar con
usted el gustazo mío gracias a cristina